my job at Twitter is to ensure user
trust protect user rights and keep users
safe both from each other and at times
from themselves let's talk about what
scale looks like at Twitter back in
January 2009 we saw more than 2 million
new tweets each day on the platform
January 2014 more than 500 million we
were seeing two million tweets in less
than six minutes that's a twenty four
thousand nine hundred percent increase
now the vast majority of activity on
Twitter puts no-one in harm's way
there's no risk involved my job is to
root out and prevent activity that might
sound straightforward right you might
even think it'd be easy given that I
just said the vast majority of activity
on Twitter puts no one in harm's way why
spend so much time searching for
potential calamities and innocuous
activities given the scale that Twitter
is at a one-in-a-million chance happens
500 times a day it's the same for other
companies dealing at this sort of scale
for us edge cases those rare situations
that are unlikely to occur are more like
norms say 99.999% of tweets pose no risk
to anyone there's no threat involved
maybe people are documenting travel
landmarks like Australia's Hart reef or
tweeting about a concert they're
attending or sharing pictures of cute
baby animals after you take out that
99.999% that tiny percentage of tweets
remaining works out to roughly
a hundred and fifty thousand per month
the sheer scale of what we're dealing
with makes for a challenge you know what
else makes my role particularly
challenging people do weird things and I
have to figure out what they're doing
why and whether or not there's risk
involved often without much in terms of
context or background I'm going to show
you some examples that I've run into
during my time at Twitter these are all
real examples of situations that at
first seemed cut and dried but the truth
of the matter was something altogether
different the details have been changed
to protect the innocent and sometimes
the guilty will start off easy if you
saw a tweet that only said this you
might think to yourself that looks like
abuse after all why would you want to
receive the message yo now I try
to stay relatively hip to the latest
trends and memes so I knew that yo
was also often a common greeting between
friends as well as being a popular
Breaking Bad reference I will admit that
I did not expect to encounter a fourth
use case it turns out it is also used on
Twitter when people are role-playing as
dogs
and in fact in that case it's not only
not abusive it's technically just an
accurate greeting so okay determining
whether or not something is abusive
without context definitely hard let's
look at spam here's an example of an
account engaged in classic spammer
behavior sending the exact same message
to thousands of people well this is a
mock-up I put together using my account
we see accounts doing this all the time
seems pretty straightforward we should
just automatically suspend accounts
engaging in this kind of behavior it
turns out there are some exceptions to
that rule turns out that that message
could also be a notification you signed
up for that the international space
station is passing overhead because you
want it to go outside and see if you
could see it you're not going to get
that chance if we mistakenly suspend the
account thinking it's spam okay let's
make the stakes higher back to my
account again exhibiting classic
behavior
this time it's sending the same message
and length this is often indicative is
something called phishing somebody
trying to steal another person's account
information by directing them to another
website that's pretty clearly not a good
thing we want to and do suspend accounts
engaging in that kind of behavior so why
are the stakes higher for this well this
could also be a bystander at a rally who
managed to record a video of a police
officer beating a non-violent protester
who's trying to let the world know
what's happening we don't want to gamble
on potentially silencing that crucial
speech by classifying it as spam and
suspending it that means we evaluate
hundreds of parameters when looking at
account behaviors and even then we can
still get it wrong and have to
reevaluate
now given the sorts of challenges I'm up
against it's crucial that I only predict
but also design protections for the
unexpected and that's not just an issue
for me or for Twitter it's an issue for
you it's an issue for anybody who's
building or creating something that you
think is going to be amazing and will
let people do awesome things so what do
I do
I pause and I think how could all of
this go horribly wrong I visualize
catastrophe and that's hard there is a
sort of inherent cognitive dissonance in
doing that like when you're writing your
wedding vows at the same time as your
prenuptial agreement but you still have
to do it particularly if you're marrying
500 million tweets per day what do I
mean by visualized catastrophe I try to
think of how something is saved benign
and innocuous as a picture of a cat
could lead to death and what to do to
prevent that which happens to be my next
example this is my cat Eli we wanted to
give users the ability to add photos to
their tweets a picture's worth a
thousand words you only get 140
characters you had a photo to your tweet
look at how much more content you've got
now there's all sorts of great things
you can do by adding a photo to a tweet
my job isn't to think of this it's to
think of what could go wrong
how could this picture lead to my death
well here's one possibility there's more
in that picture than just a cat there's
geodata when you take a picture with
your smartphone or digital camera
there's a lot of additional information
saved along in that image in fact this
image also contains the equivalent of
this more specifically this sure it's
not likely that someone's going to try
to track me down and do me harm based
upon image data associated with a
picture I took of my cat but I start by
assuming the worst will happen that's
why when we launched photos on Twitter
we made the decision to strip that geo
data out
if I start by assuming the worst and
work backwards I can make sure that the
protections we build work for both
expected and unexpected use cases given
that I spend my days and nights
imagining the worst that could happen it
wouldn't be surprising if my worldview
was gloomy it's not the vast majority of
interactions I see and I see a lot
believe me are positive people reaching
out to help or to connect or share
information with each other it's just
that for those of us dealing with scale
for those of us tasked with keeping
people safe we have to assume the worst
will happen because for us a
one-in-a-million chance it's pretty good
odds thank you
[Applause]